hello everyone
welcome to another video tutorial on the
python series of tutorials by simply
learn today we are going to learn about
lambda functions in python in our
previous video we have already seen
the important built-in functions and how
to write user defined functions in
python in this video we are going to
learn about lambda functions in python
so what is the lambda function
a lambda function
is one of the simplest ways to define a
function in python a lambda function is
an anonymous function defined without a
name and does not have the def keyword
it can accept any number of arguments
but can only have one expression
so the function is always defined using
the lambda keyword which you can see it
here
so here we have the syntax for lambda
function we use the lambda keyword
followed by the arguments and then we
have a colon after that we have the
expression that we want to evaluate
cool
now
moving ahead let's
look at an example of using lambda
function in python
now
if you were to add two numbers in python
using a function you would ideally use
the def keyword followed by the
function name and then pass in the
arguments you can see the arguments here
a and b
then
use the return statement to get the
value of the addition so we have written
a plus b
and finally you will call the add
function and pass the argument values to
get the result
now this operation can be done using the
lambda function as shown here so we have
defined a variable called add which is
equal to and then we have used the
lambda function followed by the two
parameters or arguments so here a and b
are the arguments and then i have my
expression a plus b see all this you can
do it in one line
and then to call the function you use
print
followed by the variable which is add
and then you have the arguments 3 comma
8 so the addition of 3 plus 8 would be
11.
now you can see that instead of using
the df keyword we have used the
lambda keyword and there is no
parenthesis required anything after the
lambda keyboard is treated as a
parameter or argument
so
we use a colon to separate parameters
and the expression in our case the
expression is a plus b
now moving ahead we look at
the pros and cons of
lambda functions so lambda functions are
suitable for simple logical operations
so when we want one expression in return
we can use the lambda function
a lambda function is used as a parameter
to
different functions such as map filter
reduce we will see all this in our demo
session
now coming to the cons of using
a lambda function
so
lambda functions can only evaluate one
expression as i told you earlier
you cannot write a dot string to explain
all the inputs operations and outputs as
you would do in a normal user defined
function that uses the df keyword
and finally lambda functions are
generally not preferred when you have to
declare a function with multiple lines
of code
now let's head over to our jupyter
notebook where we will learn about
lambda functions and how to use it in
different ways
so i'm on my jupyter notebook let me
just go ahead and we'll
rename the notebook as
lambda
functions in python
okay i'll just click on rename
cool
first of all i'll write a
general user defined function using the
def keyword let's say i want to add two
numbers
so this example we have already seen in
our slide
so the way to do is i'll use the df
keyword followed by the
function name and then i'm giving my
arguments or the parameters
after that
let's say i want to store
the addition of a plus b in a variable
called result so i'll say result equal
to e plus b
and then
i want to return my output that is
result so i'll say return result
so this is how you will normally create
a function in python
if i run it and then i'm going to call
my function using the function name that
is add and then i'll pass in
my parameters a and b let's say my a is
3 and b is 4.
if i run this
i will get the result 7 which is fair
enough now if i want to
do the same operation using
a lambda function i would do something
like this let's say i'll create a
variable called add
and then i'm going to use the lambda
function
followed by the arguments a comma p
then i will give a colon and say a plus
p
after that i just say add
and then pass in my parameters
3 comma 4 if i run it you have the same
result that is 7.
now let's see another example using
lambda functions to add
a number this time i am going to pass in
only one argument
so i will say add equal to
lambda
my argument is x i'll say x colon x plus
let's say i want to add x with
100
i'll say
print
add let's say i want to add 50 with 100
if i run it i have the result 150
all right
now in python there is no need to assign
a lambda to a variable you can directly
call it let me show you how to do it
i'll say
lambda
a comma b which are my arguments
again this time i am going to use
a multiplication
operator
since i want to do a
product of a and b
and after that
using another parenthesis you can
directly pass in the
arguments so there is
no need to explicitly assign a lambda to
a variable
so if i want to find the product of
let's say 15 comma 30
if i run it i have the result 4 t
let's change the arguments let's say i
want to find the product of 5 comma 7
the answer is 35
so this is known as an immediately
invoked function expression or iife
which is often pronounced as iffy
you can also use keyword arguments using
lambda functions let me show you what i
mean
i'll create
my lambda function and assign it to a
variable called product i'll say
lambda
let's say my arguments are x y and z
after that i'll give a colon and say
x multiplied by y multiplied by z
next i'll say print
my variable that is product
and here i am going to use keyword
arguments so i will say let's say
z equal to 5
x equal to 10
and y equal to 4.
you can see here
this need not be in an order as you have
defined the arguments
if i run this i have the result the
product of 5 multiplied by 10 multiplied
by 4 is 200.
now you can also
use default arguments
suppose i say add equal to i'll use the
lambda function
and say x comma
why i am assigning a default
value of let's say 15 and z let's say
i'll assign a default value of 24
then i'll give my colon followed by the
expression that is x plus
y plus z
now i'll say print
add now here i'm going to only pass in
my value for x since i've already
given a default value for
argument y and z
so
my function only needs
one argument that is x so let's say i
want x to be
20.
if i run this
you see the result here so 20 plus 15
plus 24 is 59.
now you can also use the
asterix
args parameter or args
so this allows you to define as many
arguments as you want
so i'll say addition
equal to
lambda
then i'll say asterix ergs
so this will
allow us to pass in as many arguments as
you want
and i want to find the sum of
args so i'm using the inbuilt sum
function in python
now i'll say print
my variable name that is addition
and let's say i want to find the sum for
four
values or four arguments let's say 20 to
40 and let's say
50
if i run it so the value is 112 so 20
plus 2 plus 40 plus 50 is 112
cool
now lambda functions are also used with
higher order functions which take one or
more functions as arguments
or return one or more functions let me
show you
so i'll define a variable
called higher underscore
ord underscore f u n which stands for
function and y d stands for order
so i'll declare my lambda function
suppose the parameters are x
and then i have a
function
then followed by a colon i have
expression as x plus
function of x
now i'll say
higher underscore ord underscore
f u n
and i'll pass in my two
arguments let's say my x is 20
and for this
function
i'll have
a lambda function defined i'll say
lambda x
colon
x multiplied by x
now
let me just run this and i'll show you
the result okay so what it did was
it added
my value of x that is
20 with
function of x or f u n of x what is f u
n of x fun of x is
x multiplied by x so 20 multiplied by 20
is 400 so this becomes 400
plus x
which is 400 plus 20 hence the result is
420
so this is known as a higher order
function
now let me show you another example
let's say i want to display order event
by
taking the value of x
i'll say lambda x colon
here i am going to pass in my expression
if x
mod
2
will give a space here
i'll say and
odd
or
even
now i'll give my argument value let's
say 30
the result is even because 30 is
divisible by 2
i'll just change this to let's say 15.
if i run it the answer is odd because 15
is not divisible by 2.
let's say i have 150 the answer is even
now moving ahead
so let's write a lambda function that
checks if a string is a substring of the
given string
so i'll create a variable called sub
underscore
string
now i'll assign this
variable with a lambda function i'll say
lambda
my
argument let's say string
i'll give the colon and pass in my
expression string in
let's say my string
has this message welcome to
python
functions
tutorial
okay
so we are going to check
for string let's say in to welcome
python java anything whether it is
present inside the string which is
welcome to python functions tutorial
now let me go to the next line
i'm
going to print
sub underscore string
and let's say i want to check for my
string
let's say java
if i run it it gives me false because
the word java is not present inside my
string welcome to python functions
tutorial
suppose i write
python
now one thing to note here is
the p is
small and here the p is in capital
letter
if i run it it again gives me false
because
python is case sensitive now if i make
this as capital p it will result in
true
let's say i want to say
instead of tutorial let's say i have
training
if i run it it tells me false because
the support training is not
there in the string welcome to python
functions tutorial
i'll change this to tutorial
you see here i have my result as true
all right
now let's see how to use lambda
functions using filter function so we
are going to filter a list of numbers
using a specific condition
so i'll create a
list called num
let's say it has values 40
10 40
then we have 56 27 let's say 33 15 and
70.
so this is my list
now i'm going to use
my lambda function
along with the filter function
so i will pass in my variable as greater
i'll say list
then i am going to
pass in the filter function and inside
the filter function i will use the
lambda function
and i'll have my
argument as num
and my expression let's say i want to
filter only those values
which are greater than 30
so i'll say num greater than 30 this is
my expression
or the condition that we want to check
i'll give a comma
and
i'll have my next argument as num
and let's go ahead and print the
variable greater
if i run this there you go you can see
here we have all the values from the
list or the numbers from the list that
are greater than 30 so we have
40 56 33 and 70 so
10
27 and 15 are
less than 30 and hence those three
values were not printed
now let's say you want to filter a list
of numbers that are divisible by four
so i'll create another list called list
one
and
let's say i'll have the
same
values in the list so i'll just copy it
and i'll paste it here
and i'll create my variable let's say
divide
i'll say divide equal to
list one
i'll use the filter function
followed by
the lambda function
i'll say x
colon
then i'll have my expression
x
mod 4 should be equal to equal to 0
i'll give a comma and pass in my
next argument as my list 1.
now
i'm going to
say print
divide
okay
okay i'll remove the bracket here there
is no need of a bracket here cool
and we'll delete here as well
now let's run it
okay there is one error here this should
be list one
let's run it again
okay there is some error let's debug it
okay so this should be the function list
cool
there you go
so here you can see we have two numbers
40 and 56 that are divisible by 4.
the remaining
numbers are not divisible by 4 and hence
were not printed
all right
now let's go ahead and explore how you
can use the map function along with the
lambda function
so the map function accepts two
arguments a function and a list it takes
that function and applies it to every
element of the list and returns the
modified list
so we'll create a list called
list2
let's say equal to
and again we are going to have the
same values in the list as above
so i'll just
copy those values
or the numbers and i'll paste it here
okay
now
let's say
i want to find
the value of a number multiplied by 2 so
i'll say
let's say the variable name is double
the num or double the number
i'm going to use the list function
followed by the map function this time
and then we'll have our
lambda function
i'll pass in my argument as x
colon
followed by the expression so x
multiplied by 2
i'll give a comma and then we'll have
the list that is list 2
there's a spelling mistake here this
should be list 2 all right
now
i'm going to say print
double
underscore the
underscore num
make sure there is no space
in the
variable name
now if i run it
you can see here we have multiplied
every number in the list by 2 so
10 multiplied by 2 is 20
40 multiplied by 2 is 80. similarly 30
multiplied by 2 is 66
15 multiplied by 2 is 30 and again we
have 70 multiplied by 2 is 140
so this is how you can use
map function with
lambda functions
now suppose you want to find the power
of a number let's say i want to find the
power of a number raised to 3.
so i'll create a list called list
3
let's say i have values 2 comma 5 comma
10 comma 6 comma 4 and then let's see we
have 12
i'll say
cube
so i want to find
the value of a number raised to the
power 3
so for that i am going to use the map
function followed by the
lambda function
i will pass in my argument x
and then
here i am going to use the inbuilt
power function in python so p o w
my
argument x
and this x i want to raise it to the
power of 3
and then i'll have my
next argument which is
list underscore 3
or list 3
okay
now
let's
print the list so i'll say list of
cube
i'll run it
you can see here
so 2 raised to the power 3 or 2 cube is
8 5 cube is 125 10 cube is thousand
6 cube is 216 4 cube is 64 and 12 cube
is
1728
now coming to the final section of the
demo where we'll see how to use
the reduced function in python along
with the lambda function and then we'll
use the lambda function within a user
defined function
so first let's look at how to use reduce
in python
so reduce applies a rolling calculation
to all items in a list you can use it to
calculate the total sum or to multiply
all the numbers together so reduce
function is a part of
func tools module so to use the
reduce function you need to import the
func tools module first so i'll say from
funk
tools
import
my function that is
reduce
and then i'll say
let's say i have my list 4 this time
i'll create a list
i am going to take the same values as
above
and i will pass in within a list
and now
i want to find the sum of all the
numbers that are present inside this
list called list 4
so i'll do that using my reduced
function
followed by the lambda function
so i'll say x
comma
and i'll give my expression as
y colon
x
plus
y
give a comma and pass in my last
argument which is my list itself which
is list four all right
and then i'll say print
sum
let's run it
there you go so 2 plus 5 plus 10 plus 6
plus 4 plus 12 is 39
so this is how you can use
the
reduce function in python suppose you
wanted to find the
product of all the numbers present
inside the list so you can just
use the
asterix instead of the addition operator
now if i run this
you have the product of all the numbers
that were present inside the list that
is list four we have twenty eight
thousand eight hundred
now
let me show you the final demo that is
using a lambda function in a user
defined function
so first of all i'll create a
user defined function to calculate the
value of a quadratic equation
so
for some of you who don't know the
formula quadratic equation it is
ax square plus bx plus c so we are going
to use that formula in our function
and find the value using
lambda function
so i'll create a user defined function
called quadratic
and it will have
three arguments a comma b comma c
i'll say
return
and here in the return expression i am
going to pass in my lambda function i
will say lambda
x which is my
argument i'll say x
colon
then i'll have my equation which is a
x square so i am saying a multiplied by
x
raised to the power 2 so i am using
double
asterisks
plus
b
multiplied by x so this becomes ax
square plus bx
plus
i have my constant that is c
now
just go to the next line
i'm going to create a variable let's say
f
i'll have my
user defined function name quadratic
i'll pass in the values for a b and c
let's say a is 2 b is 3
and c is let's say 5
and i'll call a of 1
the value of x is 1
the value of a is 2
the value of b is 3 and the value of c
is 5. now let's run it and see the
result
so
ax square plus bx plus c
for
equal to 2 b equal to 3 and c equal to
5 the result is 10.
now let's change it to let's say i want
the value of x as 2 if i run it
you have the
equation evaluated and the result is 19
all right
so that brings us to the end of this
video tutorial on using lambda functions
in python i hope it was useful and
informative if you have any queries
please feel free to put them in the
comment section of the video thank you
for watching
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here